we've got a voicemail number it is two
one nine two david p you can call any
time of day here's what one caller had
to say do you feel that you and other
progressive host understand other parts
of america that aren't on the coast okay
I think that's it I kind of just
mentioned this right which is we we
really do have multiple Americas in the
United States and I do think it is
difficult if you spend most of your time
on the coasts in Los Angeles San
Francisco here in Boston New York City
whatever it probably is difficult to
immediately and fully understand what
life is like in a lot of the United
States now certainly traveling to those
places with some frequency is a useful
thing feel like I learned a lot about
the United States through my travels to
Pensacola and Wisconsin and a lot of
different parts of the United States so
I think that that that's an important
thing I I do think you can learn a lot
about what life is like for people in
different parts of the country by
reading I don't think that there's any
there's any doubt about that but I think
you're bringing up a fair point which is
we do have at minimum two and according
to some as many as nine or ten different
sort of many countries in the United
States groups of states if you look at
Europe for example and the size of
Europe and the size of European
countries and how much life changes even
within those small countries nevermind
across those countries there's a lot of
different life being lived in the United
States when it comes to the different
region so I think I make a concerted
effort to understand what life is like
for Americans in different parts of the
United States but I think that it would
be very useful for all hosts progressive
conservative in cities in the middle of
the country to be exposed to as much of
this country as possible why not go
hosts even co-host should absolutely and
well okay see Pat Pat wants to talk now
about his upcoming plans but we'll do
that a little bit closer to the vacation
because I think that that is an
interesting story for people okay we've
got a great bonus show for you today
including an active ingredient in coffee
that is the same as the active
ingredient in viagra this might be the
infamous cob feffy that we've heard so
much about its coffee plus viagra is
cops EFI we'll talk about that and more
on today's bonus show please do become a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership speak to you then